you know if they ever make a sequel to
passion of the christ' I think that Paul
Rudd should be in it let me go early
July 1 most cooperative inmate 4 months
running god net just showed up they said
your door was always open our Idiot
Brother stars Paul Rudd Elizabeth Banks
Zooey Deschanel and Emily Mortimer the
story of this guy played by Paul Rudd is
just like the most innocent carefree
kind man you could possibly think of I
mean he literally does not have a bad
thought towards anyone even people who
do him wrong he's like he always finds
the beauty and the goodness in them he
thinks that there are this real beauty
and everyone and that if you just treat
everyone you know in a really good way
even if they treat you wrong that the
goodness will shine through and that
good things will happen to you at the
same time however he doesn't really have
a job he doesn't really work and he's
kind of living off of his family his
three sisters and the main female leads
in this film and he kind of goes in
between them and his mom and he's trying
to find a place to live and he keeps
causing problems because he's just so
nice that he doesn't realize that he
causes a lot of problems well I gotta
get back to work on the tongue y'know
what it's a cross-pollination between a
tomato and onion think of the time it'll
say when you're making spaghetti sauce I
really like Paul Rudd I'd like them in
everything I've seen and he's really the
heart of this movie his character is
just so fun to watch because in actually
a little bit inspiring actually because
I was watching the movie I was thinking
man I wish I could respond that way to
people sometimes because people say
stuff to him and do stuff wrong to him
and he's just like man it's alright you
know whatever who cares I need to be
more like that character I'm just like
you know whatever just let it pass and
the three sisters are all really good
Zooey Deschanel Elizabeth Banks and
Emily Mortimer all create a really
realistic family with Paul Rudd included
I really felt like they were family I
mean they did a great job they all had
great chemistry with each other also
Adam Scott or me as a lot of people have
been saying apparently I look like him I
I don't know I'm whatever he's pretty
good in this Toby - I never wanted a man
feeling the kids heads with stupidity
check it out
can't one of you just take him please
what's wrong with my sister she's pretty
but she's bossing tell me exactly what
he said he said that your personality
gets in the way of your looks your very
good looks
do you have Tourette's Steve Coogan's in
this movie and it's a completely alone
comedic role his character is like
really low summit you don't like him at
all there's really no comedy in his role
so people who are fans of his comedy
might be disappointed by his role in
this movie also the cameraman from
Cloverfield TJ Miller is in this film
and he was pretty funny I liked his
character a lot to him and Paul Rudd
worked really well with each other now
there are some flaws I have with this
film and my main ones really is that
it's just really not that funny I mean
there are definitely some humorous parts
and overall it's an enjoyable film to
watch but it's not really a laugh out
loud comedy at all times it can drag a
little bit the story wasn't terribly
interesting and because of the juvenile
nature of Paul Rudd's character at times
the film kind of felt that way too
now I try and do good I just screw it up
top of it all I broke down smoke to the
kid who lives across the street from me
okay I didn't just hear that that's how
it broke down I went smarter the kid
lives across the street from me you
don't tell your parole officer that you
just got high so basically this film is
a really fun movie to watch Paul Rudd is
really good all his sisters are good
they all work well with each other and
they feel believable but it's just
nothing really that special it's sort of
just the I'm gonna sit back and watch
this movie it'd be a good rental maybe
for like a rainy day just to watch it
with some friends so I'm gonna give
already a brother a B if you like this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck mine eyes